[Music]
what do you guys think would be the most
inappropriate kind of like can i [ __ ]
your grandmother since right now an
appropriate type of circumcision no I
feel like I'm playing family huge most
inappropriate prize to win as an
eight-year-olds at a hot youth hockey
tournament man spreading your mouth up
loves off
what a [ __ ] a guy spit in your mouth
scar eight years old a lifetime supply
of blockbusters oh bottle of alcohol
tires watch videos of women sitting on
civilians and reading in like $2,000 on
a sybian word is like yourself and we're
any to say buddy you should do it if
it's really nice I heard it looks
amazing if I was a girl kind of like the
thing that you're all right now yeah
that big vibrate the [ __ ] out of your
shell those we tipped off the ball and
you were left Mercury's not retrograding
to her anyway okay so the prize actually
is $200 worth of cannabis products
you hotkey turn what this cannabis have
age limit 18 or 19 I think it's 21 no in
Canada I think it's 19 that's such a
random number yet 19 plus I know certain
provinces it's 19 a drink as well okay
I'm being American here going it's look
21 I wouldn't have known if I was in so
they don't have like CBD gummies for
kids and stuff
there's no way why would they do that Oh
true CBD it doesn't get you high but I
don't know maybe to that ball that's a
ball yeah this is the bone so pipe yeah
later
there's like a lighter panic what do
people say or they like he's eight years
old
that's why you got a screen or sponsors
before they sponsor event row and that's
why you got to stop playing hockey it's
a kids hockey game tournament yes okay
let me tell you they're having a pizza
party and they don't even know a sponsor
is by CBD they eats like 30 pizzas so
the story is this eight-year-old went
went went to this hockey tournament with
his grandpa and they had all these
different sponsors that they had and
they had like brown paper bags in front
of the products that were prizes that
you could bid on so it's kind of like an
auction and he and so the grandpa gave
him ten dollars to spend on raffle
tickets and then he told the
eight-year-old like God just bid on
whatever you want so then this kid ends
up bidding on this prize and he thought
that it was nothing but chocolates like
because okay so the thing is because the
actual products were not at the event it
was a photo of the products and they
like the people who donated it they did
say it explicitly said like for adult
only but the grandpa is pants cuz he's
like I'm gonna [ __ ] his for adults only
this is a kid events geared towards
families why was [ __ ] cannabis
products yeah go Gramps and then so the
people who donated they were like well
hold on the person who came to pick up
the prize which was the dad of a year
old he had the option to reject the
actual product but he ended up taking it
anyway oh maybe he wasn't working he was
just like huh
kids a little [ __ ] and he wants to
[ __ ] destress for himself yeah and so
the grandpa was like he's like you know
what it doesn't matter you shouldn't
have had that prize like determine the
tournament [ __ ] up for not screaming
the people that are donating welcome
funny yeah why can't there be prizes for
adults sometimes at kid event hey this
should stop worrying our kid prizes so
[ __ ] boring is just for him I agree
but I think for the grandpa's like logic
here is like well but now my grandson's
pissed that he didn't win all this
actual chocolate he can't eat the thing
that he thought he won that's your
choice fool what kind of prize he could
eat it me yeah like coupons I [ __ ]
swords and [ __ ] like all kind of can you
imagine a kid I just imagined this
[ __ ] with three teeth holding a
whiskey bottle like he just want
something yeah I'm saying what if the
chuck-e-cheeses had prizes that for
adults doing those games yeah [ __ ] you
too that's why we have Dave & Buster's
guy yeah but nobody ever goes the David
Buster's I wish we did I went there for
a little bit I've been at Dave and
Buster's
it's not like I'm lengthy that's true
would you rather have alcohol or a
stuffed animal see stuff down gamble
what would you do with the stuffed
animal cuddle in it they should do that
in Vegas for adults Circus Circus Circus
is so dirty though it's kids no I mean
like like you play games and then
tickets come out and then you can win
like a lap dance that's pretty cool
joint comes out a lot of that comes out
when you play that game when you spray
the water and the horse goes across and
you hear a stripper drop inside
she rolls out of the ball drop it here
but don't see climbs out she's like okay
you're the guy this is a cloud machine
where the strippers already laid and
they're home hided trying to get the car
to coming up you try to grab the hooker
come on man I got a sweet money you and
your friends just get on one side and
lift it up and this you just roll out
shake the machine because you ordered
Lepidus gene come out you get two
strippers for one yeah and then when
she's done with the lap dance she's like
okay you guys gonna give me a boost
she comes back into the [ __ ] machine
dude that would be so far so inefficient
I don't think they'd like that really
the strippers yeah of course not
oh sure we should stop treating them
like animals thank you it could be male
or it could be male or female strippers
oh good for you Joe you guys all
pictured females didn't you just like
when you think doctor do you think only
men well we did think she comes out yeah
well I was just thinking there was one
in that particular game but I think of a
doctor I think of clipart of a doctor
with the [ __ ] line rounding on is the
thing with the jacket yeah in a
stethoscope
it's not usually the case I think of
George Clooney really George Cooley
doesn't look like a doctor yeah sexy ass
doctor okay yeah yeah no George
Clooney's an attractive man even now you
think he's attractive yeah I think so I
don't think he's attractive now no no I
mean more attractive let me help you out
with that
did you know that he just sold a company
for a billion dollars and it's a tequila
company oh my God he's [ __ ] awesome
you know he sold Cass amigo yeah I think
he's fine how much does he get to keep
all this helping all it's attractive you
looks like a doctor like a doctor says
the doctor
why does he look like a dr. sexy Beverly
Hills doctor man one time I was um I was
getting like I was going in for a sec
irregular like blood check of like you
know just a you know your regular STI
blood check and in then I was at a
clinic because I didn't have insurance
and then I the doctor was like the the
doctor is like hey um do you do you have
any like anything want me to take a look
at you me like mom something else I'm no
I'm just getting some blood work just
like you know every few months or
whatever you wanna see your dick no well
here's why you want to see my dick he's
like okay well I have him a new
assistant and she's never actually seen
me do like a physical check for
something like this before he's like put
you mind if we just kind of if I use you
an example like yeah sure that's fine
whatever
wow that's so nice did he go like this
and go well no he wears a heaven I um I
was like I saw the assistant I was like
oh my god she's kind of she's pretty you
know did you got hard well I didn't get
hard so here's with like ideally ideally
you wanna like you had a couple of
pretty strokes in to make it more that's
the thing right in your head you want to
be like maybe like 40% engorged you know
but you don't want to be completely
erected I mean in my head I'm like oh
man be kind of cool if I got a little
erect and then I did get erect was like
perfect I was like perfect in between
where I wasn't too hard whereas creepy
that's true just want to be impressive
so she's sitting there and she's like oh
so I'm there and like how do you could
draw once it starts getting engorged in
and they were going to get to that point
you starting about diarrhea so does he
get to engorged
yeah keep the car no man I can't do that
you guys are artists it's difficult but
I had it perfect right so then he's like
kind of checking my [ __ ] out okay and
with lumps everything looks good
did you when he pulled your pants down
did you look at the girl immediately
like what's up right no no but like I
definitely was like she was like yeah I
moved it I made it do the thing ya you
oh yeah you fights to it all the bouts
that's fun girls love the bed I love the
bounce they think it's you it's so funny
afterwards I remember thinking like I'll
see my dick was looking like perfect for
the for this took make a good impression
on her and then as he was leaving he's
like thank you and she kind of like like
smirk Douglas yeah she liked my dick and
I like celebrated in my hey she was a
fan so that's like I went oh [ __ ] that
would be crazier than a fan senior I get
scared you just volunteered your dick
like that I mean I for science it's for
science
no no no no it's not my dick not weirdly
glad that you said you said it's so
different I said it's not what's not
weird it's just different color I didn't
say it was weird I did they say anything
about the rumors around youtuber that
yours your multicolored dick is weird
yeah multi-coloured dick no it's not
like okay yeah I showed you because you
know how my nipple okay I showed you my
nipple last time right you did you were
here okay so look now you know how my
nipple see how my nipple is that the tip
is light it seems like but around it is
dark it's what useful kinda has the same
thing where it's like the top of my dick
is light and then the dark is in the
bottom of the underbelly of it is like
dark first or good light like a reverse
Orca like a reverse arc and then the tip
is a different color like completely as
well yeah yeah but reverse yeah I
imagine me laying like this and my big
going against my that's why I was
confused by what he was doing I just
like that you got everyone to think
about your dick with pretty good good
feet I didn't fight him I pictured an
orca on his body is what I really
pictured I pictured his dick I think
just stick to it
yeah same it was wonderful
I wouldn't know cuz I don't know if it's
circumcised or not no it's circumcised
uncircumcised
oh yeah right right no use I meant to
say the officer
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]